you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news coming up on today's
programme
the future of energy we visit a nuclear
fusion site after scientists make a
major breakthrough in sun technology
john kerry travels to mexico amid
tensions over a plan to increase
investment in fossil fuels and limit
foreign firms investing in renewable
energy
plus concerns about toxic chemicals
found in turkish landfill sites that
contain uk plastic packaging
[Music]
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show where we track the
changes happening to our world right now
and challenge those coming up with the
solutions
we begin the show with what's being
dubbed a major step in finding
alternative energy solutions nuclear
fusion uses the same process that powers
the sun and could provide a near
limitless electricity source that's
crucial for tackling the energy crisis
in the uk
well now scientists in oxford working on
the technology have created a
record-breaking
megajoules of fusion energy which could
pave the way for a future of fusion
skies science and technology editor tom
clark has more
the glow is a soup of superheated ions
howling around the hollow doughnut shape
reactor
then the moment of fusion happens and
ends just seconds later
if it looks a bit like science fiction
that's because until recently it was
no one has captured this much energy for
this long from fusion this is a quest it
matters so much to find a sustainable
form of energy for for the planet and
over the last few years we've had a
bunch of hurdles challenges that we've
had to overcome
that the results today show that we can
do that and we can overcome all those
hurdles those challenges that's why it's
so important to us fusion's potential is
huge it's the process that powers our
sun its fuel is in limitless supply and
unlike nuclear fission that runs
conventional nuclear plants there's no
long-lived waste
with nuclear fission atoms of
radioactive metals split releasing
energy in the form of heat
in nuclear fusion two different forms of
hydrogen fuse together making helium
but fusion releases four times more
energy than nuclear fission
this is the engineering model of the
inside of the jet machine the
temperature needed to make fusion happen
is 10 times hotter than the sun 150
million degrees so when this thing is
running it's the hottest thing in the
solar system so nuclear fusion does have
the potential to transform civilization
but the practical realities of making it
happen here on earth
are enormous
here at jet for example they must use
more energy to achieve fusion than they
get from it
but it's proven the science and is
developing the tools like precision
robotic handling needed for the next
fusion machine nearing completion in the
south of france these results help us to
go to the next step and prove that
fusion can be a power plant for the
world
the eter machine say fusion scientists
is the final step before a commercial
reactor only commitment stands in the
way
we have shown them
that this can work from an engineering
point of view from a physics point of
view the challenge is there they cannot
hide
but
we've shown them that this is possible
now take it up and take it seriously
the truth remains fusion power won't be
with us for decades too late for the
current climate crisis
but given a fusion reactor makes four
million times more energy per gram of
fuel than coal oil or gas its potential
to create a brighter future is just too
great to ignore
tom clark sky news oxfordshire
the united states special envoy john
kerry arrives in mexico tonight to find
ways for the two countries to coordinate
on climate-related issues new mexico has
been criticized for limiting private and
foreign firms that invest in renewable
energy favoring its state-owned
electricity company while also
increasing investment in fossil fuels
the united states is prepared
to be as helpful as we can be not not
because
it advantages us
but because we are all in this together
no one country can solve the climate
crisis
well let's bring in our u.s
correspondent mark stone now and mark
what's behind this meeting then
well look i mean this is another uh
signal perhaps and we've seen others
haven't we of the commitments and the
pledges made in glasgow uh a few months
ago beginning to unravel domestically
around the world countries which made
big big pledges
are now struggling um or indeed um
outright just forgetting
the proposals and the pledges that they
made and mexico is one of those
countries uh it's clear from what the
president in mexico has been suggesting
that they want to prioritize domestic
power companies and those domestic power
companies are themselves prioritizing
old dirty energy
and not new clean energy and so as as a
um as a world leader uh john kerry in
the united states wants to put pressure
on its neighbor not least because they
want north america as a continent to be
seen to be doing more uh in in the
climate change fight they are trying to
put diplomatic pressure on the mexicans
to change their ways and that's why he's
there and he'll be holding important
meetings and he will as he suggested be
offering the mexicans some help be it
financial help or technological help to
try and persuade them
to go
more green but but i think as i said
this is another example of the concerns
that we are seeing around the world
where those grand pledges were made in
glasgow and they're very difficult to
keep mark thank you
now for some of the day's other climate
news and boris johnson has dismissed
calls from the labour party to introduce
a windfall tax for oil and gas companies
that have reported bumper profits the
prime minister told secure stamina such
attacks would clobber supplies and
instead gave his backing to further
exploration
what he would be doing mr speaker is
hitting the energy companies at
precisely the moment when we need to
encourage them to go for more gas mr
speaker because we need to transition
now to cleaner fuels
a new coal-fired plant has been approved
in eastern china but the state firm in
charge of the project says it'll help
the region's low carbon transition the
xiang energy group says the new plant
will be more efficient using less coal
than the national average
china's president xi jinping has pledged
to reduce coal use in the country after
2025.
new drone footage has revealed the
destruction left by a cyclone in
madagascar destroying homes and damaging
crops that were just weeks away from
being harvested
cyclone batsirai is the second tropical
storm to hit madagascar in two weeks as
the country struggles with food
shortages after a prolonged drought
experts say that extreme weather events
like cyclones will become more frequent
because of climate change
there could be more rare mountain hares
in the peak district than first thought
according to a new nighttime survey the
game and wildlife conservation trust
says it's welcome news for the species
but they still face many threats
including climate change due to less
snow in the winter making them more
visible to predators mountain hares are
native to scotland and died out in
england during the last ice age but were
reintroduced in the mid-1800s surviving
now only in the peak district
now where does our waste go well many of
you will separate your household waste
into the correct bins and do your bit
for the planet but campaigners have long
claimed that some of the uk's plastic
waste ends up in landfill around the
world and now a new report by greenpeace
says that uk plastic packaging has been
found in dump sites in turkey and is
contaminating soil with toxic chemicals
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
we're getting straight to discussing the
climate issues of the day now with
climate activist michaela loach who
joins us from jamaica and tomber
co-founder of the e3g think tank so
welcome to both of you nice to see you
both so a huge step closer to conquering
one of the biggest scientific and
engineering challenges of them all that
was the statement from the chief
executive of the uk atomic energy agency
as we heard from tom clark nuclear
fusion is still some time away from
being commercially viable but it could
in theory be an endless supply of
emissions-free power so tom berg are you
celebrating is this a breakthrough that
could turn our power grid green in
future
it's a small step forward in the science
of very sophisticated nuclear
technologies it's not really anything
that's going to help us very much with
climate change as tom
pointed out uh it's some way away it's
actually been some way away for about 50
years um and i think this isn't really
the kind of breakthrough it's being
hyped up at the real point is
as the government's already recognized
we have to decarbonize our electricity
system by 2035. so we already have to
have solved all the problems of finding
our ways to make renewable electricity
and energy efficiency mean that we have
secure supplies of electricity and this
won't come in too long after that so it
can't be a magic wand now if it turns
out to be a lot cheaper than anything
else that will have a role to play but
i'd be very surprised at that
so michaela decades away potentially
very expensive as well although as tom
says the cost could potentially come
down but is that a reason not to invest
in it for the future because climate
change is not something that's just
going to stop being a problem even in a
few decades time
yeah i think that the thing is that um
we need to be investing in renewables
now and
as thomas said um we we have a limited
amount of time and to tackle the climate
crisis now i think right now what we
need to be thinking about is how can we
invest
money into
energy sources that are
renew that renewable that aren't going
to have an impact on the planet but also
are replicable for other countries all
over the world because this is a global
crisis that requires global
collaboration
and things like this nuclear fusion it
requires huge amounts of um high level
resources in order to happen um it only
will really be possible in the most rich
countries all over the world um which
would then kind of lead to more
inequality and so i think that instead
we could focus on things like renewables
like solar and things that are
replicable all over the world and things
that are accessible and that also are
able to be owned by the community so
then we can actually center justice in
that as well um because that's an
important thing we need to be thinking
about when we're thinking about energy
sources for the future well yes and tom
everyone will say obviously renewable
sources are
an excellent option when you're looking
to turn the grid green however they will
also that the the criticism that often
comes up is what about when the sun
doesn't shine and the wind doesn't blow
you need a reliable source of energy i
mean
do we turn to to our regular nuclear
plants to provide that do you think
no and what happens when your nuclear
power station isn't operating and
they're obviously not operating some of
the time for routine maintenance which
you can predict just like you can
predict when the wind won't blow or the
sun won't be shining um but actually
about 25 of the time they're not
available in unplanned ways so we have
already got to deal with and learn how
to deal with the variability and we're
getting more and more sophisticated in
being able to do that as we digitize the
economy and we digitize the electricity
system so i think that fear is really
somewhat exaggerated that's interesting
and michaela what about this idea though
of investing in technologies now that we
don't know what their capability is in
future but it's important to always keep
the options open i mean to what extent
can technology we don't know about now
potentially
answer some questions and solve some
problems on climate change going ahead
i think that we all like i think we all
kind of find this technological stuff
really exciting like this idea that we
could create this completely um
different and high-tech world i read a
lot of sci-fi so i think i read a lot
about this and people's imaginations
around it but i also think that that
would be the case if we were investing
enough in renewables already i think
that what we need to do is think like
how can we protect the planet how can we
make sure that we're all going to be
okay and safe and just and then we can
think about investing in in things that
maybe aren't as certain in technologies
like this but the priority should be
let's make sure that all of us are safe
let's make sure that we have um energy
that is accessible and that is
affordable and um is available for
everyone all over the world and that
prioritizes justice and means that
people can live a free life as well and
then we can think about let's maybe like
look at this more um high-tech stuff and
i think that we need to think about our
priorities and where we put money in
that way okay let's move on to our next
topic shall we because we all know that
eating well could improve our long-term
health but a new study suggests that
eating more lentils beans and brown rice
and less red meat could have more than a
decade to our life and the study
published in the plos medicine isn't
about the environment but as the
argument goes eating less meat could
help the planet so tom as we were saying
that this research focuses on how a
healthy diet can lengthen your life but
it happens to be very planet-friendly as
well this diet that they're talking
about is it mainly because it doesn't
involve any meat so
could research like this
point people in the direction of making
green lifestyle choices without them
even realizing it i think that's
absolutely right and as you can imagine
anything that would extend my life by
ten years i'm pretty interested in
i think i think the
the point is exactly right that this is
and the evidence is now becoming a more
and stronger and stronger
actually a light
a diet that's light in meat is actually
very good for your health so very good
for you personally but it's also very
good for the planet because the
particularly the sort of uh
sort of mass production of uh meat for
the market actually produces not just
really bad effect on climate change but
it also produces an enormous amount of
pollution of water uh and destruction of
biodiversity that goes with it so i
think this kind of advice helps us to do
the right thing rather than penalizing
us for doing the wrong thing yeah and
michaela what is the best way to to
nudge people into making greener choices
is it a bit like this study which wasn't
designed to nudge people uh planet-wise
but do you think if you appeal to
people's self-interest they're more
likely to make changes or do you think
that underestimates people's ability to
see the greater good when it comes to
climate change so i think that what's
what this study shows and what a lot of
actually climate solutions show is that
all of us are interconnected to the
planet and to each other um that us
being healthy it was also healthy for
the planet that the planet being healthy
is healthy for us and that there are so
many co-benefits that arise when we
tackle the climate crisis in a way that
we're addressing all these connections
and i think that the best way that we
can get people on board with climate
action is to meet people where they
already are so if you have a friend or
an uncle who likes something already
like show them how that's connected to
the climate crisis show them how they
could either like benefit from from
tackling it through that way or why what
that they care about is being um
threatened by the climate crisis because
all of us care about climate already i'm
sure every that everyone something you
care about is connected to the climate
crisis in some way and we can talk about
the bad stuff we can also talk about how
things can be better if we tackle um
many of these issues um with this lens
of realizing the connections and so i
think studies like this are really great
because it's like yeah of course um
eating less meat is better for the
planet and better for our health um but
it's showing that there's they're all
connected it's not just we're doing it
as this selfless act we're doing it also
as a way that can help us and help the
planet and help each other but but
thomas the problem of talking like this
about choices individuals make actually
take the responsibility away from where
it should lie and that's governments and
policies and those bigger decisions like
building new coal-fired power stations
isn't isn't that's where we should put
our focus
these are not either orders you you need
both you need certainly need government
to actually play a rather more active
role than it's playing for instance in
the way we uh allow our food and
agriculture policies uh to play a better
role but actually governments are driven
at the end of the day by what their
voters and what people want and what i
think is is really important about the
sort of evidence like this is it it
tends to encourage in many ways the peer
pressure on people as we saw with povid
you know when given the chance most
people want to do the right thing and
it's something even on covey the
government managed to underestimate the
extent to which people will do the right
thing if they think everybody else is
doing it
okay we must leave it there i can see
you nodding there and michaela but we
are out of time for a tom burke mikayla
loach really good to talk to you thanks
very much indeed
and that's it for me but tomorrow i'll
be joined by environmental lawyer tessa
khan and dan caesar chief executive of
fully charged thanks for watching i'll
see you next time
[Music]
you